pues a ver general prevé en primer lugar
es importante tener en cuenta lo que en
el ataque como tanto aunque nos falta
cierta información el tipo de 30 de
ataque que ha habido porque deja viejos
as 33 están este ataque aéreo no sobre
la central como tal sino con contra
edificios adyacentes que esto es muy
importante tener en cuenta
asumía podemos asumir que evidentemente
que el proceso de targeting de la
selección de objetivo no era
evidentemente contra contra la central
un problema mayor también tenemos que
tener en cuenta y esto es muy importante
sobre todo sobre radio sobre realidad lo
que
para que hubiera una posible fusión
nuclear serial
tendrían que parar que sucede muchísimas
cosas porque el tema de el mismo
material nuclear
utiliza plutonio este tipo de cosas lo
que sí que podría haber afectado pero ya
es lo que es eso que las mismas
autoridades australianas en ese primer
momento que se fue a controlar
antecedentes acepta por lo tanto de
momento de momento sabemos relativamente
poco así que si la comunidad
internacional está haciendo las cosas
pero en este momento no tenemos que
estar más preocupados la vuelta
y que puede buscar por tanto rusia
controlando esta central nuclear
estratégicamente porque es importante
pensemos al final una central nuclear no
deja de tener parte del impacto de
impactos de poderes a nivel a nivel
psicológico en el elemento más
importante que es es la producción de
energía cne cuando sea el momento se
quiere cerrar la luz para dificultar o
para para incrementar digamos la presión
sobre la población ucraniana
posiblemente lo podrá hacer somos que
esté la central nuclear es la más es la
más grande de europa que ha seguido de
que planteará las las autoridades
secretarías cambiantes pero sigue
actores operando por lo tanto pues eso
posiblemente el escenario más posible es
que intentarán utilizar esto uno para el
control físico y después sobre todo para
controlar la ley